unsere lebenszeit hier auf der erde ist
im vergleich zur lebensdauer eines
sterns oder der des universums quasi
nichts
sie geht in einem wisch vorbei während
sich im universum kaum etwas getan hat
aber das heißt nicht dass das universum
für immer existieren wird zumindest
wahrscheinlich also fliegen wir zusammen
zum restaurant am ende der welt und
beantworten die frage wie wird das
universum enden vor 13 8 milliarden
jahren entstand unser universum im
urknall
darüber sind sich inzwischen die meisten
wissenschaftler einig aber wie unser
universum einmal enden wird können wir
nur vermuten
lange zeit haben wir gedacht dass der
urknall das universum zwar ausgedehnt
hat gravitation aber irgendwann die
überhand übernehmen wird und beginnt
alles wieder zusammen zu ziehen
das ergibt auch sinn da gravitations
felder unendlich weit wirken und der
aufwärtsbewegung des urknalls
entgegenwirken
das ganze kann man sich dann vorstellen
wie einen gegenstand den man in die luft
wirft erst fliegt er mit hilfe der
kinetischen energie nach oben
bis die anziehungskraft am höchsten
punkt ein kräftegleichgewicht herstellt
und den gegenstand dann wieder nach
unten zieht
unser universum würde nach diesem punkt
wieder zusammen schrumpfen
der abstand zwischen galaxien wird immer
kleiner und materie bewegt sich im
allgemeinen immer schneller aufeinander
zu das universum erhitzt sich schwarze
löcher werden größer und größer weil
mehr und mehr materie hinein fällt bis
schließlich eine art umkehr urknall
passiert alle schwarzen löcher
fusionieren zu einem ultra großen
riesigen schwarzen loch und die gesamte
materie des universums ist wieder auf
einen punkt konzentriert die
singularität und von da aus kann es sein
dass das universum direkt wieder neu
geboren wird in einem weiteren urknall
das ist der big crunch und laut dieser
theorie spricht nichts dagegen dass
dieser vorgang schon unendlich oft vor
uns passiert ist und es immer so
weitergehen wird das universum wird
regelmäßig neu geboren und dann
zurückgesetzt nichts kann diesen
neustart überleben aber zumindest kann
dann wieder neues leben entstehen
eine wie ich finde sehr schöne theorie
1998 wurde dann aber eine überraschende
entdeckung gemacht das universum dehnt
sich gar nicht immer langsam aus und
kommt irgendwann zu einem stopp in
wahrheit der sich immer schneller aus
entgegen der kraft der gravitation dass
es so als würdest du einen gegenstand
hoch werfen der dann
magnetisch nach oben weg fliegt die
kraft dafür soll aus der dunklen energie
kommen was aber eigentlich nur ein name
ist den wir diesen phänomen gegeben
haben denn beobachten oder nachweisen
konnten wir diese energie bis jetzt noch
nicht und das obwohl rein rechnerisch 68
prozent unseres universums aus dunkler
energie besteht 27 prozent besteht aus
dunkler materie und nur fünf prozent des
universums ist aus der materie die wir
kennen und aus der wir bestehen
im moment gehen wir davon aus dass
dunkle energie eine kosmische konstante
ist das würde bedeuten dass die
energiedichte überall im universum
gleich bleibt wenn sich das universum
also weiter ausdehnt und somit sein
volumen vergrößert muss mehr dunkle
energie entstehen da die energiedichte
nicht kleiner werden kann
normale und dunkle materie tun das aber
nicht und so wird der anteil von dunkler
energie mit jedem moment in dem sich das
universum ausdehnt größer bis das
universum fast nur noch aus dunkler
energie besteht
das würde dann dafür sorgen dass sich
das universum immer schneller ausdehnt
der raum zwischen sternen clustern wird
immer größer und die energie die in form
von strahlung des weltall fliegt wird
immer stärker roth verschoben
nach einer bis 100 millionen jahren in
diesem szenario können sich keine neuen
sterne mehr bilden da gaswolken
inzwischen zu ausgedünnt und verteilt
sind
mit der zeit wurden die noch
existierenden sterne zu schwarzen
löchern werden und auch die wurden nach
milliarden von jahren durch hawking
strahlung verschwinden
am ende würde das universum eine
konstante temperatur erreichen die an
jedem ort gleich ist eventuell erreichen
wir auch eine maximale entropie und
materie ist überall im universum
gleichmäßig verteilt sobald das passiert
ist kann sich nichts mehr bilden alles
wäre tot
das ist dann der big freeze das große
eingefrorene universum in dem für den
rest der zeit einfach nichts mehr
passiert bzw
einen ausweg gibt es dann doch noch
durch quantenfluktuationen kann nach
zehn hoch zehn hoch 56 jahren ein
weiterer urknall entsteht setzt bei
maximaler entropie dass es zwar in
unvorstellbarer riesiger zeitraum aber
es ist nicht unendlich und somit kann es
auch in dieser theorie einen kreislauf
geben und das ist auch gut so denn der
big freeze ist momentan das
wahrscheinlichste ende für unser
universum und es wäre echt mega
deprimieren zu wissen dass irgendwann
einfach alles zum stehen kommt und dann
nie wieder etwas passt
jetzt eine dritte möglichkeit gibt es
aber noch und ich denke das ist das
spektakulärste ende des universums
der weg wird oder das große zerreißen
würde dann passieren wenn dunkle energie
noch viel stärker ist als wir bisher
gedacht haben und zwar so stark dass man
sie phantom energie nennen würde
sie hätte das potenzial das universum so
schnell auseinander zu reißen dass sich
der raum irgendwann schneller ausdehnt
als lichtgeschwindigkeit galaxien sterne
planeten sogar schwarze löcher und
einzelne teilchen wurden
auseinandergerissen werden weil der raum
in dem sie existieren sich zu schnell
aus dem nicht einmal mehr photonen
könnten einander erreichen und jedes
teilchen würde alleine in einem riesigen
raum umher irren ohne das ich jemals
zwei treffen würden
das wäre wahrscheinlich das einsamste
ende des universums
ich finde irgendwie immer wieder mega
krass darüber nachzudenken das ende des
universums und damit das ende von
realität
danach kommt nichts mehr oder vielleicht
passiert auch nichts mehr aber danach
lebt nichts mehr um das ganze
wahrzunehmen und das ist generell ein
ende und einen anfang von etwas gibt von
der realität ist für mich auch
unvorstellbar aber da habe ich schon
gesprochen warum existiert nicht nichts
und warum kann man sich das nicht
vorstellen
schreibt eure gedanken zu dem thema und
in die kommentare welches ende des
universums haltet ihr für am
wahrscheinlichsten diskutiert mit mir
gerne in den kommentaren und wenn ich
das video gefallen hat ihr beim einen
kanal noch nicht abonniert habt dann
überlegt euch mal ob wir das machen
wollt denn dann verpasst ihr kein neues
video sowie zb nächsten donnerstag wir
uns das nächste mal sehen werden bis
dahin autor ein weißer ring